now here's the question where you look
at first today before we actually launch
into it I just want you to think about
how could you prove this we looked
before about the different ways you can
prove things right the different ways we
can mathematically prove things I think
I gave you four examples didn't I and
there's this others how could you go
about it if you were trying to do it
directly which is the normal way you
prove things where would you even begin
you certainly couldn't do it by
exhaustion I mean it goes forever right
anyway it's just a thought for you
because I mean we often say oh I have to
prove it this way well half in this case
how else would you prove it
induction is a very elegant way of doing
what were our four steps how does an
induction proof stick together the tape
right so what's our very first step here
very first step what am I going to test
okay so the first allowable case which
I've said for you they they might have
just easily have said this okay in which
you would have said okay it's positive
and one is the first positive number
okay so I'm going to test in equals one
okay let's give it a go forward to the
power of 1 minus 1 is 4 minus 1 which is
3 okay great if you really want to make
it super obvious by the way that this is
true enough a multi-port 3 and say it's
3 times 1 because it's 3 times an
integer and this one makes it a multiple
anyway it's evidently true okay it's
true for our first allowable value now
one of the reasons why I'm introducing
this kind of fall into your dream up on
the board is because you get to this
next step and you say assume what do I
assume now I've given you a sentence up
here have an i but we want some kind of
mathematical equation here something I
can prove or disprove assume substitute
what could I write though we
mathematically equivalent to what this
sentence says okay obviously it's got to
have a
4m minus 1 in it but what can we say
about it
any suggestions so I'm going to say it
must be equal to and this is why I wrote
this is 3 times 1 to try and lead you in
that direction it has to be 3 times some
integer right now you can you can choose
any integer you like I'm just going to
choose P you'll see why in a second
now remember peak I'll just it can't
just be anything right so I have to say
where what kinds of conditions should I
put on P if I want it to be multiple
right it has to be a whole number
doesn't it a multiple I'm not sure
really if that includes negatives but it
wouldn't matter anyway because our first
case is positive and as you get bigger
it gets more positive so I'm going to
say P it's also going to have to be a
positive integer or some code so I'm
going to assume that that is true now
what tnp I would approve well I should
have probably said that what am I going
to prove this statement in here right
it'll be the next case a long water what
would that look like instead of K I've k
plus 1 y know what should I have on the
right-hand side
now it's going to be three times well it
can't be three peek at it right because
it's the next case over I'd assume the
way this works you know afford the end
it's going to get bigger it'll be some
other number but that number also better
be another positive job right okay
so how can we go about this at this
point what do you usually do you set up
you're required to prove okay so what
might you do here any suggestions okay
you can you want to probably start with
one of the sides don't you okay I looks
like the left-hand side will be a bit
easier to work with and it will provide
us something that we can use the
assumption in right so I'm going to say
the left-hand side equals okay by the
way just something I noticed as we're
walking around in our outdoor lesson
yesterday please please don't skip any
lines in this right I mentioned this to
a couple of you but not to all of you
because we're all displaced but you know
Letta conduction is the classic example
on proving something but you already
know what the result is right so you get
no credit for actually doing you know
the last line they're getting getting
the answer right the process is
everything but the means by which you
get there is everything okay so every
lie you skip it damages the strength of
your argument okay
so therefore you know for instance I
could have written here and I will write
four times four to the K minus one
because that's what it is right index
laws okay
but I would never put that as my first
line even though it's so obviously true
I wouldn't put it as my first line
because it ain't the left-hand side okay
so I'm trying to make sure this is this
argument it's an argument trying to
convince you is as watertight as
possible there's no room for you to say
well this rubbish come from and I'd have
to explain it all I kind of think it
should stand on its own right and an
exam in the HSC we don't get to mark you
based on later on your come and explain
oh this is what I meant this what you
buy down that if the sole means by which
we can judge you and your understanding
okay so make sure it's this kind of
quality
now what I've used my own excellence to
simplified a little bit right I know in
my head I want to bring in this guy
somehow and end here how can I do it by
the way um there's many ways to skin a
cat I can see at least two primary ways
as you go about doing this let me show
you one of it I'll show you the other
okay this is what I'm after a four to
the K minus one right now is there a
fort of a K minus one is there one of
them in this layer that I've written
there is is in there it's just not quite
as obvious right because I've got this
extra four hanging around front okay if
I just want four to the K minus one what
is the difference between this line and
this line and the answer is I've got too
many of these I've got extra ones right
I've got four of them here but I only
want one I kind of just like get rid of
it because convenient to me I have to
include it in there right so here are my
three spares if you like okay there's
the four to K minus one which I'm after
I can work with this thing and this is
what I'm left with okay because there
was one year three there that's my four
right now I can use my assumption I'm in
a position to use what I assumed here
that's three P okay by assumption
now can you see where it's going to go
you see where it's going to go I'm
trying to end here
3q to beat me because I don't know what
two years but it's obvious enough once
you take out the factor right that's
three times this okay
now you're probably in most cases could
get away at this point just say that's
3q okay but let's need a little more a
little more finesse later on when we do
inequalities it's going to be very
important people's 4k here how can I
justify all of that stuff turning into Q
right on what grounds can I call that Q
can see a positive integer right how do
I know that this thing in here must be a
positive integer how do I know I just
pull their hand over well it's made of
two pieces isn't it it's got P and
that's a positive integer right and it
also has 4 to the K right now fort of a
cave I know that's a positive integer
how do I know because I put some kinder
I didn't say it today first because K
has to follow the same conditions that M
and does right so because you know 4 to
the K doesn't have to be a positive
integer if I make K you know negative 1
not integer anymore but because K has
these particular qualities right that's
why you can say okay sum of two positive
integers also a positive integer so
that's what I'm going to arrive
okay
so now it's true for that next value
along and equals K plus 1 the next case
and you can finish the explanation from
there but did you see what we did so the
way we did it your assumptions as normal
okay
but you want to twist them turn this
time here so that you can use the
assumption now thank you I did say you
could do it another way it's not very
very different but just in case you
didn't like what I did here see how I
looked at this point I said is there a 4
to the K minus 1 and my answer was yes
there was I rewrote it like this to make
it clear okay the alternative way for
how I could do this is take your
assumption here take your assumption
before you leave it rewrite it you can
rewrite it like this right 4 to the K is
equal to 3 P plus 1 isn't it I just move
the one over the other sign ok so now
you can see the reason why some people
like writing it like this and then using
that is their assumption can anyone tell
me why would you do it that way rather
than the way I've already done it
because when you get to this point right
or maybe this point right 4 to the K
it's just there you don't need to do
this weird how do I rearrange it
you just take your 4 to the K you stick
it in and you will get the same result
at the end it works exactly the same you
see why 3p plus 1 minus 1 it cancels out
right ok